l'attak la plus fréquente que les
personnes peuvent subir c'est le rendre
somewhere qui est la menace numéro une
en matière de cybersécurité en 2021 il
ya aussi le phishing qui consiste à
envoyer des fichiers mail fictifs à des
utilisateurs pour récupérer leurs
données personnelles
alors comment réagir quand on est
victime d'une cyberattaque
il serait préférable de débrancher le
câble ethernet du pc de manière à
confinant va sur le pc ensuite il serait
préférable de aussi pas écouté les
instructions de l'assaillant et de
directement contacté contactée la cnil
comment se protéger en amont pour éviter
ces cyberattaques au maximum la première
étape est de savoir sécuriser son mot de
passe
nous sommes partis interrogés les
yvelinois pour mieux connaître leurs
habitudes
oui il si ce mot de passe partout parce
que j'ai peur d'oublier certains je
pense qu'en mettant le même partout je
suis sûr d'avoir d'avoir bon les
applications importantes où il ya des
données sensibles par exemple gmail et
utiliser un mot de passe ou pour les
applications que j'utilise régulièrement
mais sinon les petites applications
je mets souvent le même alors faut-il
changer de mot de passe ou pas créer un
mot de passe compliquée christine fraude
au professeur de management des systèmes
informatiques nous en dit plus jean pas
choisir un deux trois quatre
on va choisir le prénom de ses enfants
il faut plutôt choisir un mot de passe
qui a au minimum 12 entre 10 à 12
caractères et qui comporte donc des
chiffres des lettres des caractères
spéciaux les mots de passe ils doivent
est unique on a souvent l'habitude
d'utiliser
des mots de passe identique pour des
sites différents et ça c'est à proscrire
il est important de se protéger contre
la cyber criminalité car les cyber
attaques se multiplient comme dans la
ville de houilles qui a subi une attaque
de rançon logiciel le 29 janvier dernier